so Stefan is the VP of digital sport at
Nike and the author of the new book
almost almost new out Thursday velocity
which we'll talk about in a little bit
but Stefan is basically the the software
guy at a hardware company very plush
comfortable hardware but hardware
nonetheless footwear you can call it wa
re and by I want to start you been at
Nike for for 15 years and the last 10
years especially all about digital and
I'm curious how we were talking about
this yesterday how the Nike experience
with customers used to be one where you
know you kind of have the ads and the
marketing and you get you convince the
customer tube to buy a product and
that's the end of the relationship until
next year but the whole idea of digital
and the idea that you're behind a
digital is to to start the experience
with the purchase to create a digital
environment that starts there and I'm
curious how that fits in at Nike I mean
this this behemoth company that does so
much about shoes but conceivably not not
so much about digital yeah I think first
and foremost were a company about people
and consumers and understanding
consumers and athletes and and when you
do that and when you try to be have play
relevant role in their lives footwear is
obviously one thing we've spending an
enormous amount of time researching and
understanding but the opportunity that's
presenting itself right now is
completely different in that the
relationships we have and this is
something we've learned from Lake e+
early on our are so much more impactful
when when someone comes back to the
brand two or three times a week to sink
Iran versus what it used to be which was
convince someone that we had something
amazing which we do then you buy it and
you have a great experience but with a
product but we don't know anything about
that experience we don't know how you
use it why you use it what you like
about it what you don't like about it
and right now we're in a completely new
era where technology just unlocked
something impressive
so you mentioned nike+ nike+ was this
it's started in 2006 right yeah the
collaboration between nike and apple and
in your book you have this great moment
where you're you're adamant with steve
jobs and jobs was talking about how he
thought that apple was going to handle
the engineering and nike was going to
handle the marketing yeah um but that is
not actually how it turned out I mean it
was more it was more fluid than that
yeah and that's how it started I think
that um because people view nike a
certain way like an amazing consumer
company but focused on marketing and
great products and i think this notion
that we actually understood engineering
and how to use software to to create
services that are indispensable to
people was new to a lot of people and
but but the relationship was structured
that way in that Apple are amazing
engineers and they deliver the hardware
at the time but when we built out the
service nike+ calm first time I think it
was great just to see the team at Apple
and jobs his reaction to that being you
know wow this was just not what we had
expected you to do so that's great and
and I should have mentioned I key plus
was is basically an accelerometer right
that that that's the hardware yeah he's
the secret kind of node inside there is
the accelerometer and that would fit
inside your shoe it still does fit
inside your shoe and then the software
is kind of how you track how the
environment in which you what you do
with all that information at its
gathering about your movement in your
speed and every right right it started
off as this the sensor in your shoe that
connected through radio with a little
receiver that you clicked into your nine
all right because at the time you know
we didn't have the ecosystems we have
and then we created once you plugged in
your nano the data was synced with
through itunes with nike+ calm and
that's how we made the whole experience
come to life now that was one of the
first at least in on my radar it was one
of the first moments where we're a big
company created a consumer device that
allows tracking of movement and it was
focused on running it was it was kind of
tied into running shoes you have to had
to have the shoes on but it was really
this kind of moment when all of a sudden
it was quite the I mean why are we keep
on calling it living by numbers it's
this way where all of a sudden that the
data that you're generating through
day-to-day life becomes evident
and tangible and something you can
actually use and respond to and and
that's a very profound profound shift to
make people conscious of that that what
they're doing with their lives like that
yeah you know it's interesting we use
that we have this saying you can't
improve what you can't measure and it's
been amazing working with athletes pro
athletes for four decades seeing them
come to campus go into our labs and and
all the equipment we have to test
measures see how they're doing the
biomechanics experts that can break that
down all that was for the purpose of in
the beginning creating better shoes
creating better apparel because but from
all we understand from these athletes
and how they move and then you quickly
realize how what a benefit they have to
all this information and how it helps
them excel and you know and then when
you but we but you look at sensors and
you look at what's going on today we
said well why wouldn't we take all this
knowledge all this information and give
it back and put it in the hands of every
consumer in the world you know we have
we say we bring inspiration and
innovation to every athlete in the world
and then it has a little last race and I
said if you have if you have a body or
an athlete and and i think that there's
that opportunity to take something that
was exclusive and elite and bring it to
everyone is incredibly powerful and data
just becomes information that leads to
knowledge and at the end of the day that
becomes motivation and that creates an
incredibly interesting cycle just
because you have that information you
and you know so much more about yourself
it's you're able to stay motivated and
where you've never been able to before
right so so we'd say i mean when we when
we brought about it in wired we brought
up the Hawthorne effect which is great
kind of observation of science on how
when you when you measure people and
when people know they're being measured
when they know they're being monitored
there's this tendency to actually
perform differently or perform more
consciously so it's it's tied to this
actually this factory back in 1920s
where they were trying to measure how
many basically widgets electrician
they've made electrical widgets they
made and when they turn the lights on
people would act would make more widgets
and when they turn lights off people
would make more widgets because they
thought they
was going on both times so so that
Hawthorne effect it's something that
keys in with with nike+ and all these
self monitoring devices because people
are all of a sudden aware that of their
own actions and and that is you know in
and of itself just that awareness is
this powerful catalyst it's incredible
when you think about it we always start
by doing you know trying to understand
people what motivates people and what
propels us when you look at it you got
to look at it through the lens of least
amount of uncomfortable change because
on your uncomfortable chain least amount
of uncomfortable change because if you
go after something and you say okay we
want you to go from being completely
inactive to run a marathon no one is
going to be able to do that but but if
you make it in small increments and you
give someone the opportunity to track
that so for instance the FuelBand that
we launched in January here in New York
is another very simple way to have
something a device where you set
yourself a daily goal and you track your
progress against it but you don't make
it this massive change you just say just
be a little bit more active and that
ties back to the Hawthorne effect
because you're now you have the ability
through your phone you sync it
wirelessly through bluetooth and then
you see how your friends are doing and
you have this sense of there's a sense
of community there's a sense of goal but
you also have this notion that you know
in a positive way there is a nudge that
keeps you keeps you going so I think
just that the fact that you have that
makes it much more much more powerful
right so so the field and chris has it
on I have it on we there about eight of
us at Wired now have gotten them they're
hard to come by but there what what is
so cool about them or kind of compelling
is that they're not tracking everything
right they're not they're not giving you
this plethora of metrics and charts and
graphs and and there are those tools
that will do that there are tools that
again they're accelerometer based but
there are tools that will kind of let
you track with GPS and they kind of
build other sensors in there but but you
guys are very deliberately made it a
very simple and and not not kind of
overwhelming amount of data that's
coming out the user yeah it comes back
to you know respect the human being
don't let technology you know lead let
the let the experience lead and I think
if you try to pack all the technology
into something you'll get something
that's really bulky really complicated
really complex and actually measures a
bunch of things that you don't
necessarily need we're trying to as
Chris said earlier today you know let
this doom what it's good at doing just
let me track how active I am during the
day the phone does a bunch of amazing
things let the phone do that but it
needs to be unintrusive because when you
work with athletes you find out that
they just want zero distraction you
can't have that you can't have something
that that you think about wearing and
really one of the hardest things i think
is to know to say no to edit away and
say yeah it could do all these things
but what's the what's the most
interesting thing that is the least
intrusive thing that you could have that
still helps you get to where you need to
get to and then you tap into the back
end the incredibly powerful social
backend just that bluetooth enables so
you know you connect the band to the
phone the phone to the world to everyone
you care about and all of a sudden you
have an ecosystem of services that is
indispensable right you can compete with
ya and things like that so so it tracks
some tracks calories and steps and then
there's this metric that you guys
invented called fuel points yeah fuel
Nike Fuel Nike Fuel got to get the
brandy right yeah so it's it's it's an
interesting unit because it's in the
thousands well actually you got a video
about it that describes it right yeah oh
yeah we can let's run the video and then
I can talk to how we got to it runners
walkers basketball players or break
dancers they'll have one thing in common
Nike Fuel the ultimate measure of
activity of sport of commitment of your
entire athletic
telling you more about yourself than you
ever knew before it isn't bought or sold
it's earned from the moment you start
moving the more you move the more you
earn view is calculated the same way for
everyone so whoever you are and however
you move we're all connected connected
by Nike Fuel so so what I think is
fascinating about that is it's a
completely new number that I mean so
that that video was is ostensibly to
kind of elucidate what it represents but
it doesn't represent anything I mean it
represents certain things right movement
and things like that but it said it's a
metric that doesn't translate as this is
okay this is the number of steps I'm
taking or this is the amount of calories
I've burned it's just a new notion that
you guys I guess have decided is is the
ultimate simple target because you want
to get to 2,000 or 3,000 fuel points for
your daily expenditure yeah we found
this was we came from working with
running and runners were where that
where this started was you see this
incredible power in in measuring how
you're doing right and if you're running
you care about how far you ran or how
fast your brand or how often you ran but
when you look across there aren't that
many things that allow you to compare
with other sports so each sport has his
has its thing and we spent a lot of time
thinking about this and sort of said
that if there was a currency that could
unite all athletic activity there is an
incredible power in that and calories
are great but they're based upon
consumption what you know what do you
consume what do you burn and they're
oftentimes correlated with weight loss
and we're more about you know stay
active be active we spent a ton of time
researching this we worked with a ASU
Arizona State we worked with leading
scientists that could correlate
accelerometry with um fuel coxa j'en
consumption to be able to give a measure
that wasn't just made up because one of
the biggest hurdles is you introduce a
currency and you call it Nike Fuel the
first thing people are gonna go why
would I care about that you know what
why would that be interesting to me is
this just a branding thing
marketing thing we spent an enormous
amount of time understanding the body in
motion and through accelerometry
correlating that with oxygen kinetics
how active are you and the best way of
measuring the activity is oxygen
kinetics when you do that you can see
from sitting down to working at an
officer being in school to walking
jogging running sprinting there's a very
distinct correlation between how you
move and how much oxygen uuuu consuming
and through those we were able to
correlate and provide the same number
based upon how hard you work to everyone
yeah and that then became like you feel
but but the reason it's important is you
want to have something that makes it
possible whoever whatever you do and
whatever your sport is to compare
compete challenge with every athlete in
the world and it and what's really
really fascinating is how quickly a
number that was completely unknown
becomes a reference point so you and I
talked about it yesterday you know the
first thing you ask someone you set
yourself a daily going on the FuelBand
and then you try to hit it and the band
resets at midnight every night but
everyone have their goal and pretty
quickly you know that a 56 thousand day
is a really good day and it's something
you didn't know but only after a couple
days of using that you it becomes this
reference point to to aspire to and I
think is what's really we're really
happy with how quickly it gets adopted
as a measure of activity so one of the
things that I think is cool about it as
well as it it takes it away and you were
touching on this it takes it away from
any specific athletic activity it's it
becomes a way for people to engage in in
their lives without thinking okay I am a
runner or IMA right cyclist or I mean
you don't you don't you want to be
active but it's not necessarily putting
somebody in one of these buckets the
sport specific buckets which which you
know was when I when Nike started I
think it was about ten years ago you
guys had this tracking program online
for runners it was not nike+ but before
that and I thought it was awesome but it
didn't I you know I run only because i
have to i love it as an activity but i
mean i like you know whatever i like to
ride a bike but but but it's so without
being a runner
not identifying as a runner i couldn't
engage in that and so this this actually
breaks away from that and its interest
it's interesting to me that you kind of
created a metric that does does get you
away from one specific activity yeah no
one and what's interesting is a lot of
people look at us and say you know we're
obviously a sports brand first and
foremost and we work with with amazing
athletes and traditionally we would come
at it you know if you look at a pyramid
of activity where the professionals at
the top and then you kind of all of us
or many of us kind of aspire to that and
when we create and we create product for
that athlete because they have the most
discerning there are most discerning
their needs are such that all of us can
benefit from it and and we do products
for that we do we have some amazing
things coming out for the Olympics where
we do pressure sensing in your shoe we
can tell you if you wear a basketball
shoe how high you jump and so on and so
forth but what's interesting with the
FuelBand to your point is you you kind
of want to broaden it it were all about
the more people move the better it is so
if we have products that can inspire and
enable everyone to be more active then
that's great we will always keep the
most authentic products for the most
elite athletes as a part of our
portfolio but we just think it's in more
interesting in a more dynamic brand if
you can be relevant to everyone right so
I want to just touch on the book because
it's out comes out and you're going to
find from here to London for the book
release party and it's it's a compelling
book because it's it captures a lot of
the stuff you've learned it at Nike and
is all about kind of this this advent of
metrics and digitization of life in
general and and how we can best optimize
our lives based on those tools and I
wondered if kind of you can give us a
little sample of that yeah the book is
called velocity and I've co-authored it
with a jazz Ahmed who's the chairman of
akqa and we started this project a few
years ago just for sitting like this
talking and we said you know it's
amazing we've had their fortune he and I
to work together for over 12 years and
and we were looking at digital and
technology and and how amazing it is and
how would you know it's such a power
that you can create so much interesting
benefits for consumers for people from
but really there wasn't that much going
on that got it right we always come back
to that we love Apple right because
they've figured out a really good way of
serving their can
humor but then there were all these
other great amazing companies out there
that for some reason struggled with what
seemed to be as an approach not so
complex so we said what if we could take
our learnings you know jaws is and I are
mine learnings and just put them in the
book and it ended up being you know the
seven the seven the seven laws for a
world with the seven you lost for well
gone digital and and and all we do is
sort of say there are some filters or
parameters that that I use every day in
my work at Nike in trying to you know
use digital in a smart way that helps
people get better and the way a Jaa's
uses it and we just put our thoughts in
this and it and it's been a really
really interesting experiment to pull
this together yeah it's a great read
okay we're going to take a couple
questions and if you have a question
raise your hand and they'll microphone
will come Heather to you we have one
question from Twitter here what do you
say to people who respond why would I
share that so this is a big issue in
terms of sharing and privacy and and
people divulge in their information so
so okay I'm tracking this but why would
I want to share my friends on Facebook
it's a really really important question
and we're very careful with how we treat
we make sure that you know privacy is
first and foremost your decision it's
your call nothing is shared unless you
want to but if you're asking why would I
it is if you feel comfortable with it
there is an inherent power and you can
select in which and how wide a circle
you want to share something it could be
with your closest friends it could be
with everyone different people have
different different ways of thinking
about that but it goes back to what we
talked about in the beginning about
motivation you know cuz because it's
it's one thing when you go out and
you're active and you're doing it by
yourself it's so much more powerful when
you have friends when you do it with
people you care about it is a completely
different level of engagement when you
have a shared goal and there are a
number of those there's a bigger reason
to share your you know your progress or
your activity because because that's the
benefit that comes back for you we never
start with share it because of nikes
benefit or share it so that we could
sell it or pass it
it is never about that is about you and
if we bring value to you because you
have a good experience ultimately you
you know it's going to reflect well on
what we provide as a brand but the data
is showing nike some cool stuff I
remember from from the nike+ data that
you guys found out that more people run
on Sunday than any other day and you
found out that if people use these these
trackers five times they're basically
hooked so once you get locked into their
I've uses your you're gonna adopt it
which is fascinating thing about why
that it takes that number that that's
the magic threshold I mean I think you
can't again it comes back to this notion
of recognition when you start to feel
like we had this one we just launched
running and there were a couple people
that were skeptics and they said you
know I don't know why would I do this
this is not authentic you know Animusic
came into the picture we said well if
you if you start getting credit for your
activity and for what you do there's you
almost feel cheated so if you now go out
and you and I can guarantee you this
once you start you know whatever
tracking mechanism you use and whatever
brand you use there is it's really hard
to go in and do a workout or go for a
run or a bike ride and miss out on that
credit you kind of want that we're
driven by recognition as humans and I
think that when you start getting that
that is an incredible power that I think
is is hard to stop once you've started
it yeah all right yes we have we have a
couple over here what I think right in
the second group will give out a nice
price to the best question oh yes we
have we have a we have a door prize are
you going to open up your platform so
that other applications can be written
based on the data yes the accelerometers
are creating so moving to platform
rather than yeah package great really
good question yeah there is absolutely
and I think as many of you know in the
beginning people view open as you know
why don't you just open up and but but
open means an enormous amount of work to
make sure that you have a really really
robust and well architected platform in
order to do that in a sustainable manner
you know everything from you know
developer relations to the SDK
appropriate we provide in the
we want to make sure that we have all
that in a in a in a really really good
shape and once we do we are definitely
opening up we're I think that's one of
the powers we know really we know a lot
about sports but there are people out
there that know way more about us about
what can make this an enjoyable
experience so that is absolutely coming
and in the near future and I think that
it'll be a lot of fun for people that
are interested in taking activity data
and do things with it that we've never
imagined it will Owens the data the
consumer owns the data we you know there
is no reason for us to sit here and
hoard and collect all this the only
reason someone has benefit from the data
is because they use it as a way to get
better and all we're doing is channeling
that providing it and putting services
back that is used to someone I think we
had another question a few rows back we
still did I lose them hi I know you had
a hackathon event in South by Southwest
this year can you talk about some of the
development developer hacks that came
out of that and what other and platforms
they mashed up the Nike Fuel bandwidth
yeah it was really interesting you know
and I think Witt was one of those that
were maybe not wasn't too expected by
Nike to participate in a hackathon but
we loved it we had partnered with a
pudgy and we went that went there and
gave a group of hackers access to
tolerate the isenj said it do something
with it you know they had I think five
hours to work on it the the hacks that
came back were really interesting they
took music combined it with FuelBand and
and just tried to figure out how to todd
to enhance the app and make it more
interesting we picked up the best team
actually and invited them up to campus
cuz you you know it's an incredibly
inspiring community to work with you
know it's hard in five or six hours to
come up with a complete revolution and
an approach to this you got you got you
need a little bit more time with it but
as an experiment it was phenomenal for
us and I think that that community
really enjoyed access to these tools you
know following the the opportunity to do
more with this data all right so so you
have a question we we are able to give
away
one Nike FuelBand and there's a question
that the whoever gets it first yeah I
didn't know if there would be any
question so I thought I'll throw one out
to see if I can there is a feature on
Nike Plus running called the power song
is anyone familiar with the power song
is it's very simple yeah that's great so
on your on your phone or on your iPod
you select that the song really keeps
you going when you run out of steam and
you just hold down the button for two
seconds it kicks in that particular song
gets you you know over the hump or up
the hill or white it might be so it's
interesting we've we've tracked over the
six years almost six years we've been
working on this what those songs are and
its really really interesting what comes
back so whoever knows what in the world
is the most powerful power the power
song will get a FuelBand raise your hand
all right just just chatter you see I'm
a tiger who that you said that all right
congratulations
so so get get if somebody can grab his
business card then he will he will be
able to be the thrilling experience the
thrill of the fight all the time Stefan
thank you so much to thank you so much